super mario 3d all-stars brings together
three incredible classic mario games
super mario 64
super mario sunshine and super mario
galaxy
but there's just one big problem and
that's what we're going to talk about
in today's video people of the
internet's retroracking tour here and if
we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell we post videos twice a
week here on youtube and we also stream
over on twitch
today we're talking all about the
problem with super mario 3d
all-stars and if you haven't looked into
this too much you may be saying
what's the problem here three great
mario games available to celebrate the
35th anniversary of mario all
on a nintendo switch console that
continues to sell like crazy
well let's dive into that shall we if
you haven't heard yet guys nintendo is
making the game available for a limited
time
only and not just for the physical
release of the game also
the digital release of the game of
course you can pre-order the game right
now it goes live on september
18th and it will stay up according to
nintendo
through march 2021 here it is straight
from nintendo
please note super mario 3d all-stars
will be available as a
limited run retail edition and a digital
edition that is available for a limited
time until the end of march 2021.
once the digital edition has been
purchased on your nintendo account it
can be redownloaded and played if
deleted from your device
so let's talk about this first off i
want to try and see if we can get
inside nintendo's head for a bit let's
see if we can understand
why would they do this then i want to
explain how i think this
really does hurt gamers and finally i
want to tell you guys what
we can do about it in terms of why would
nintendo be doing this well first of all
there are no strangers to creating
artificial demand by limiting supply you
decrease the supply so demand increases
i mean all you have to do is look back
at the nintendo wii
and see how hard that thing was to get
combined with great marketing combined
with a solid fun
innovative system the demand for the
thing went crazy
and there's just something in our human
nature when we want something and we
can't get it it makes us want it even
more and that's exactly what happened
with the nintendo wii
so maybe they're trying to increase
demand which will thus
increase sales but here's the problem
with that line of thinking when it comes
to mario 3d all-stars and that is
nintendo games don't have a problem
selling on the switch
especially first party ones and
especially ones that involve mario
mario games are a gold mine on the
switch i mean if you just take a look at
the top 10 list
you've got mario kart 8 super mario
odyssey super mario party and new super
mario brothers u deluxe
all in the top 10 selling switch games
of all time
as of june 2020 so in the long run i
think this is actually going to hurt
their sales nintendo games have always
had long legs where they sell year after
year after year until they stop
making them and here's the thing
nintendo has people way
smarter than me at the helm so they know
this so now we go back to our question
why are they doing this if it's not for
sales why would they
intentionally limit the game so now
we're left to
ask the question of do they
intentionally want
the game to be considered rare well the
game itself
is for the 35th anniversary of mario so
perhaps nintendo does want to
intentionally increase the rarity of
this game and make it so it is a
collector's item
you see with nintendo it's all about the
brand i mean to this day
which consoles are most popular with
collectors you look back like the super
nintendo
the nes all those classic games that are
available on those systems you've got
earthbound super metroid
linked to the past i mean if you have
those games in your collection you
consider them
prized possessions you see nintendo is a
company
strongly tied to nostalgia in the video
game industry so maybe this is one of
those little things that they want to
try and do
now so in the future that will continue
i mean let's be honest here for a second
if you think about 30 years from now if
i pull out this game to show my
grandkids i'm probably not gonna
remember oh that game was
intentionally scarce by nintendo instead
i'm gonna say hey here's this super rare
game with three incredible mario games
on it and then the grandkids will ooh
and aw cause their grandpa has an
incredibly rare game
and thus the cycle will continue for
another generation as the future gamers
look back on nintendo with reference
okay so even if we're going with this as
the explanation though that still
doesn't explain the limited release of
the digital version of the game
i have to admit i struggle to come up
with an explanation on this one i do
let me know down in the comments i truly
want to know what you think about this
what do you think is the reason why
would nintendo be doing this if it's not
for sales if it's not for more money
what is the point here i mean maybe
they're planning to release
all of the games separately at a later
date
would they be planning to release
another version that only runs on the
rumored 4k nintendo switch i could
almost understand if they're going to
release them as standalone games but
again that'd be a little bit shady that
they wouldn't just be honest and say
that up front hey these are going to be
available on their own at some point but
right now
we're releasing them together in this
special 35th anniversary package
in fact little suggestion here if
nintendo wanted this to be a special
collector's item why not just release
a special edition of the game you know
do the steel book do the little
collectibles and have a limited run of
that version but still
give everyone else this version that we
could buy at
any point even if you accept any of
these reasons i've given here i still
don't think it makes any of it right if
somehow some way a nintendo exact
stumbles into this video let me be clear
this is not right to your fans
let me try and explain how this hurts
the people that you should care about
the most your most die-hard dedicated
fans
first let's consider the fans who are
going to buy a nintendo switch in the
future let's say
april of next year you're essentially
telling those fans that the only way
they'll ever be able to buy this game
wait a second i think i figured it out
what if they're doing this
not to build up sales of the game but to
build up sales of the console
before they release the nintendo switch
4k that we keep hearing about next year
but that doesn't make sense either the
switch is selling like crazy they can't
keep the thing in stock
okay again back to how it's hurting the
fans for anyone who purchases a nintendo
switch for the first time in april of
next year the only way that you'll be
able to buy this game is if you go
to ebay where i'm sure by that point the
prices will be
sky high i kid you not guys it's it's
crazy you can go on ebay
right now while the game is still
available to pre-order mind you
and there are already people trying to
sell copies for higher
than the retail price i don't even want
to show them here but trust me
they're there just think about how crazy
this is going to be once march rolls
around and nintendo actually stops
selling the game they're essentially
telling all the future switch owners hey
we'd rather you go
buy on ebay from scalpers where the
prices are sky high instead of buying
directly from us
again where we could have the game
digitally you don't even have to pay for
box and shipping and all that secondly
you're not only hurting the future
switch owners you're hurting the
current switch owners by forcing on us
this fear of missing out
look i consider myself to be very
fortunate right now that i still have
the disposable income to buy video games
but we're in the middle of a pandemic
right now and there are a lot of folks
out there who are facing hard decisions
with their finances as they come to
grips with losing jobs
and sure you've got six months but still
that creates this sense of
urgency that you have to go out and buy
this right now if you ever want to have
a chance of playing this
and i don't know it just kind of rubs me
the wrong way that it's happening
right now of all times and just to make
sure i'm completely fair to nintendo
here
all games are a limited time release if
you really think about it i mean you
can't go into a best buy today and buy
n64 games there is a limited shelf life
for
pretty much any product but i also think
we can all agree that this
is something very very different so what
if anything can we fans
do about this look i'm not going to tell
you to vote with your wallet here and
not buy the game because i realize it's
an incredible game that a lot of people
want to play
to be completely transparent here i put
a pre-order link on my last video and
i've already pre-ordered the game so i i
would never tell people
don't buy the game if some of you out
there feel strongly enough about it and
do decide not to buy the game then
props to you because i i'm not that
strong instead
what i would say to do is make your
voice be heard in a polite
constructive way now before you think
all hope is lost there actually is a bit
of a precedent for this if you think
back to the nes
classic remember that first run was very
very limited nintendo said it was never
coming back prices
were sky high on ebay and people kept
begging and begging and begging please
bring it back and nintendo eventually
did bring it back for another run again
it was a limited run but they did bring
it back
in far greater numbers and i think most
of the people at that point who wanted
one were able to get one there was also
the 3ds ambassador program so when
nintendo released the 3ds at 249
those people who bought it at the launch
price were actually able to get into the
ambassador program when nintendo dropped
the price down to 169 so as a gesture of
goodwill to those ambassadors they
received a bunch of
really good 3ds games for free i mean
sort of for free so what i would say is
let nintendo know how you feel about
this make your voice heard reach
out to execs reach out to people that
you know who work at nintendo
send emails you could even send letters
and here's what i would say when you're
doing this guys
be very constructive be very polite
explain your positioning
explain why you feel that it hurts
current switch owners
and future switch owners and explicitly
state
what you want to see happen and for me i
think that is we want this game to be
treated as a regular release
and not as a limited time release and if
nintendo
even after hearing us say this says no
we want this to be a special edition of
the game
then at least let us continue to buy the
digital version even after the physical
version is phased out
and guys i definitely do want to hear
back from you on this i seriously mean
that
let me know what you think down in the
comments below i appreciate you watching
as always and i'll talk to you again
soon